we're waiting for the president of the
Commission and our guest Michael heads
from the region and Commissioner Oliver
where Haley will have the honor to be
conducting the meeting today
Aloha my glasses either
so the confidence together for Albania
will be starting very shortly and we
will need your full attention thank
thank you very much everybody board for
being with us today
Prime Minister Rama and our
distinguished guests from the region are
getting ready to join us and of course
from the EU together with the President
on the Leiden with president Josh
Michelle
here they come it is my pleasure to
welcome them all to the confidence
together for Albania and it is my
pleasure as well to welcome commissioner
Oliver Mihaly who will be chairing the
conference today welcome everybody
welcome Prime Minister
[Applause]
[Music]
now we're going to struggle
[Music]
Madam President mr. president presidents
prime ministers the guests today was a
crucial day for our benya today we're
going to be showing our solidarity our
European solidarity towards Albania an
earthquake torn country and without
further ado let me hand over the floor
to our president on their line president
Michel president you can ovitch Prime
Minister Amma Prime Minister plank of
which Prime Minister Branagh which Prime
Minister space offski excellencies
ladies and gentlemen dear friends thank
you very much for joining us today in
such an impressive number I wish you
could stand here and have a look at this
room last November the earth shook in
the dead of night when everyone in
Albania was fast asleep 51 people lost
their lives
two entire families of eight perished
when the houses collapsed we have all
heard their stories with a heavy heart a
young couple who was about to get
married a mother who died trying to
protect her daughter tens of families
opened their homes to homeless when Dawn
arrived the whole country wasn't morning
and a whole country mobilized to rescue
to heal to give shelter to those who had
lost everything
hundreds of Albanians volunteers working
day and night in the dust many more
donated clothes on
this is a story of loss but it's also a
story of heroes it is a story of
solidarity among Albanians and among
fellow Europeans in a matter of hours
after the earthquake the first rescue
teams from other European countries
started to arrive in Albania 200 Italian
Greek Romanian firefighters digging in
the rubble to search for survivors
we immediately activated the European
Union civil protection mechanism and in
the following days our experts and
engineers arrived in Albania to
coordinate the operations and assess the
damage the whole European Union
mobilized for a country that is in the
at the heart of our continent and that I
hope and I'm convinced one day we'll
also be part of our union the people of
Albania know that they belong in our
European family now more than ever
solidarity hasn't come only from the
European Union
today's impressive attendance testifies
the international community strong
response to Albania Skol the whole world
has mobilized in Europe support from
Montenegro to Canada from Turkey to
Israel from Switzerland to the United
States we have seen Serbian and kosovo
rescue teams working together for their
opinion neighbours we have seen that
beyond any political divide the Western
Balkans have united in solidarity and
solidarity can
life's in fact solidarity has saved so
many lives in Albania the day after the
quake the rescue teams pulled 49 people
from the rubble another entire family
was found under the wounds of the house
covered with a thick layer of dust but
still alive and this was thanks to our
collective mobilization but when the
dust settled the international
mobilization did not stop tents clothes
and food continue to arrive after three
dramatic months most of the people who
were left stranded have already gone
back to their homes and found a new
accommodation yet Albania's needs are
still massive and must be tackled with
urgency thousands of private homes must
be rebuilt schools and hospitals need
restoration so that they can once again
host pupils and patients businesses have
been destroyed and new jobs must be
created the cost of the reconstruction
is estimated to run around 1 billion
euros and it is clear that Albania alone
cannot shoulder this burden this is what
brings us here today today we make a
promise to the Albanian people we
promise that we are in for the long run
we promise that our solidarity will
continue to be as strong as it was in
the first hours after the earthquake we
pledge a sustained wave of investment
for reconstruction
ladies and gentlemen no one can fill the
void left by those who lost their lives
yet together we can help Albania
start over again together we can build
schools and hospitals that meet the
highest standards of seismic safety
together we can reinforce Albania's
civil protection capability together we
can make your country stronger than it
was before the quake this conference
marks the beginning the beginning of our
cooperation for albania's reconstruction
in the coming weeks and months we will
continue to work together we will make
sure that the pledges are delivered
fully and on time and we will make sure
that our investment have the strongest
impact on the ground in full
transparency and accountability but
first of all we must help meet the
country's huge needs the European
institutions and member states have put
together a strong pledge the European
Commission alone is pledging 100 million
euros 12 aeneas reconstruction from the
European Union's budget that comes on
top of the 15 million I already
announced in December and it does not
include contributions from our Member
States I invite all of you to contribute
and to help Albania get back on its feet
soon
dear friends since albania regained its
freedom its people have shown their
immense potential to the rest of the
world the country consolidated its
economy and its institutions after
decades of dictatorship so many young
Albanians got university degrees and
prospered in their lives and careers and
after the quake Albanians have shown
that they are not just proud and
talented people yes they are but they
have also shown that I have great hearts
today is our time to show solidarity
today we stand at the side of Albania in
a moment of need Albania will rise from
the ashes of this quake it will rise as
a stronger and safer country at the core
of our European family I count on you
all thank you
thank you very much Madam President let
me invite now to the floor president
Michel
madame la cosa don't delay a commission
Joshua Joshua commence cosa è de madame
zema's received a time resume sir she'll
do random or excellence madam Jamis HHR
over tea cosy callate
Lisa V no innovation or arezzo dramatic
edible person
Oh sulfur Oh fun possum Bowl VI t th e
mo sir chewy vulvar see POC Serta a true
gem a deposit impaired desert Rosharon
are certain perdido fue hecho para los
zetas Litella tetris men own album la
vida de fer emos party Palace Authority
portent Edo company labels one or kala
population confront a luminescent la
resilience del bene invisible impressive
a more recent otro en la Marina
supported resilience el retiro complete
a homo sapien repose sir Colonel de
manera community tattoos also inform oh
oh modo de sólo de consejo de otra cosa
men opposite receded MO - Liz eaten or
sofa loan debt level you son envelo 800
cote de pablo Albany Nicosia a sofa
atrocity on a traditional appellate
remission la voce UNIDO substantial a
phony solitaire ah happen more a
patrolman de Turkish a certain despair
certainly the victim Oh totally
perceived as a lil Adonis Dante OC
Lusitania distribution delayed lesser
degree to the European from the film
triple threat Amazon or Avila resort
inoue-san pitocin Oh today table-service
on OC to serve a civil suit Albany
s ago conscription nitrogen bond media
item or institutions al been a partner
Anton a co-ed whatta to Allah a Mizzou
Linda Fox do not renew Robin hobb Lamont
reveille Hasan linear international OH -
dos ojos en si es hechizo
sattva ojo de vrijheid ret Col
circumstances is non pas madam Jamis you
answered o rehabilitate little suit is
infeasible Veritate Roxy deportation
civil Tuzla necessity to travel also non
dilemma a deported not a contribution
ladies and gentlemen why are we doing
this because we are one European family
Albania and Western Balkans are not far
away faceless neighbors they are an
integral part of our continent we have a
common heritage a common history and
there is also a future together we are
determined to intensify our relations
with the region we share common
opportunities and challenges in a
troubled world with interests spanning
the political security and economic
spectrum and we share the vision of
unity and solidarity among countries and
regions in Europe ladies and gentlemen I
am confident that today's conference
will be a success just as I am confident
that the Albanian people will overcome
these difficult times will build and
move ahead stronger than ever
you can count on us thank you thank you
very much mr. president now I invite
Prime Minister Adorama prime minister of
Albania to hold his speech
I must say that I am deeply touched and
I want to start by saying very simply
this thank you and please not see a
civil play dunkey won't be the show
gratia Belphegor - a curator in the
liftin shukran of one which i could
continue in all your languages to say
thank you and please if I may in my own
language
Philemon dared tell you do them thank
you from the bottom of my heart for your
invaluable support so far and please I
speak here for and from the heart of all
Albanians please support us some more we
do them thank you for accepting the
gracious invitation of the president of
the new Commission to this special
donors conference for understanding how
dark a time this has been for my country
so yes please please help as we try to
recover from damages that go beyond our
human possibilities and rebuild from the
savage blow that develops in the early
hours of November 26 last year Thank You
Ursula to you personally and to your
amazing team thank you Charlie shed also
for reading shown us from that first
moment of shock to this warm comforting
moment of such a big gathering now the
soul of the European Union this
wonderful body that has done so much to
advance peace and prosperity across the
continent historically defined by war
and it's given so
help to my country and the region I come
from during 3 decades of struggle to
build democratic states on the ruin
foundations that communism and
dictatorship left behind for our
societies you had your own earthquake
recently with brexit I was so sad too
how strange it was coming as I from a
country so desperate to be part of the
you to see a great country like the UK
decide to leave how happy I would be if
the gorgeous Albanian flag could rise to
replace the beautiful British one that
has been taken down here in Brussels but
I'm not saying please do it because I
know life is not that simple what was it
John Lennon sang
life is what happens to you when you are
busy making other plans we were busy we
were making plans and making progress
then the ground shifts people swallowed
up in it the whole country is shocked
and since then it has all been about
dealing with the aftermath the other
plans have to take a back seat
nevertheless it felt so comforting to
discover in our trade recover that we
were not alone with our dozens of deaths
hundreds of hundred and thousands of
homeless because we had so many great
friends coming from the sky from the sea
from the land from the region from the
continents and beyond to be with us and
fight with us to save lives heal us
assess damages and now seek to build new
paths for the future for him death thank
you dear friends from Turkey for the
pledge you made as the new European
Commission did right in the immediate
aftermath of the earth
thank you dear friends from the Gulf
countries United States friends in Asia
- ready to pledge and work together with
our European friends for this amazing
conference thank you dear friends from
the neighborhood the Western Balkans to
be here with me today and witness
through your presence and pledges how
much that turbulent region of ours has
changed in the last year's and how real
is our will to build for our children a
totally different place than one of
bloodshed
conflicts disputes that kept hostage the
people of our countries for endless
generations thank you dear friends from
the United Nations World Bank EAB EBRD
kfw the League of Arab states and many
more for indeed there is no limit to the
gratitude I feel to all of you the mere
fact that you all are here today is
heartwarming and emotional for me
personally and I believe for all
Albanians those watching us at home and
those who live and work in a lot of your
countries so many of them hoping one day
to come back and live in an Albania that
is developed prosperous truly European
as the dream we believe in and fight for
every day for all the help you have
given to all of us in that extremely
difficult journey thank you but it did
so often we have felt as though we are
in a fight for survival a hundred years
ago as our region emerged from the
Balkan wars and the whole world sought
to recover from the war that was
supposed to end all wars
it is no exaggeration to say that we
face the risk of annihilation the many
curses of our history stood as obstacle
to a better future
the Versailles conference was a moment
of existential threat but our friends
came good the United States France Italy
Switzerland turkey Britain all ensured
we were given the chance to show we
could take our place in the League of
Nations at the dawn of the 1920s Albania
was excited by that the idea that the
better future was possible and made its
efforts to work towards it but that
first world war did not end all worse
the second world or followed and with it
for Albania four and a half decades of
the most brutal form of communist
dictatorship this I might add in the
only country of our continent that had
more Jews after the war than before it
thanks to them breakable code of
hospitality and religious fraternity
which we proudly cherish as a light of
our eyes still today but the curse of
history was back and we were prisoners
once more the North Korea of Europe we
knew there was another world not far
away and we wanted to be part of its
that world was Europe this Europe here
and now it was a dream
the ideal the inspiration that kept us
going and still does there is more than
one reason why we Albanians are yet era
fanatics I must say a kind of unique
species in the continents of today and
so toward to 2019 at the eve of 2020
when to GreenSource were opened wide one
physical one political both combining to
leave millions of Albanians
at home and around the world utterly
destroyed the physical one is the reason
we are here the earthquake of November
26 but even as the first tremor struck
we were still grappling with the
consequences of the political earthquake
of October 18 the day two was a dark day
in our calendar when the European
Council could not decide on the official
opening of session talks with Albania
believe me the tremors ran deep into our
minds and souls we are of course not the
only country in the world to face
natural disaster though the earthquake
was a dead list of 2019 anywhere in the
world but we are small relatively poor
country big rich countries can face
disasters on their own and we have seen
many times America and other great
countries responding to natural or
humanly provoked disasters and
responding stunningly well for smaller
countries it is not so easy though I am
hugely proud of how well we coped in the
immediate aftermath every life lost was
a tragedy but that we managed to keep
the death toll at 51 was in no small
measure down to how well our nation
reacted when disaster struck
communities rallied around we saw real
courage as people rushed to help their
neighbors disregarding the threat of
more tremors in the most memorable show
of unity
I witnessed we did a remarkable job in
incredibly difficult circumstances
pulling people out of the rubble finding
accommodation quickly for everyone
without homes supplying with them than
with food and warm clothes but again
without the fantastic rescue teams and
the hand of solidarity of many of the
countries present here
the European Union first and foremost
the death toll and the many wounds would
have been far greater thank you for him
Dale
so now the dead are buried and their
loved ones mourn whilst also as we must
look into the future the future made
more challenging when we know that
17,000 people were left without homes
thousands of buildings big and small
need to be renovated and fortified
critical infrastructure needs to be
fixed
53 national and world heritage cultural
monuments to be saved the final post
disaster report suggests we'll need in
the order of a billion of euros to
repair the damage to reach big countries
not exactly small change perhaps but
manageable - the country of 4.2 million
people of whom around two-thirds live
and work abroad we have a GDP of
thirteen point five billion euro average
salaries of 420 euro and need to face a
direct damage equivalent of six point
four percent of our GDP plus a loss of
1.1 percent of our GDP to us it is a
huge sum we cannot do this on our own we
are short of money and even more than
that short of time so yes for sure I'm
here with a very direct plea please help
us with the grants and the bearable
loans we need to rebuild our shattered
homes communities and confidence please
meet our suffering with the generosity
it needs we will do all that we can and
even more than we can I ask you to do
just what you can to help you do them
and to my friends in European Union the
we asked for goes beyond the financial
or the immediate earthquake or no
earthquake death toll or not death toll
please understand how important to us is
the Zagreb summits on the Western
Balkans in the following May under the
chairmanship of our great Croatian
friends and what we hope should bring a
green light to walk further in our yet
long European journey ahead what
happened in November may be called an
act of God for the force of nature we
are powerless as they strike we have no
choice but to accept these phenomena and
try as best as we can to save as many
people as possible and to bring life
back to normal as quickly as possible
the political earthquake we suffered a
month earlier was man-made avoidable to
the families and friends of those 51
Souls lost the real earthquake November
is the worst thing ever to happen but
for the country as a whole what happened
in October felt like the curse of our
history was striking yet again I'm not
here to blame anyone I know that the
enlargement process is just one of not
few issues under discussion within the
EU family a difficult one even not at
all easy times the Union leaving but for
us we're done so much to be ready to
move from preparing talks to accession
talks then to be denied that move was
indeed a body blow
we were totally gutted like the wind had
been kicked out of us we felt hurt and
let me say humiliated
please understand and appreciate the
depth of those feelings they spring from
our understanding and appreciation of
the goods the European Union does in the
world and our desire to be part of that
but they spring to from frustration we
did everything we could and basically
everything that was asked of us yet the
answer was no
so two body blows in quick succession
but we are still standing and still full
of hope that we can do and we will build
that better future that we off to our
children I'm really encouraged by the
way the new Commission has supported us
through the both earthquakes the
physical and the political and I am
encouraged by both the new methodology
proposal France has put forward to
address and the set of accession talks
in the future and the prompt reaction of
the new Commission to make the best out
of it
by so creating the conditions for
unleashing new positive energies here in
Brussels and back home as well so if the
end of 2019 about two bad days
for my country let this day today mark
2020 as the year of reconstruction
solidarity and hope for Albania and I
very much wish for the Pyrenean itself
because I strongly believe the interest
is mutual as the future between the
European Union and the Western Balkans
if Robert Schumann was right and he
certainly was when he declared that
Europe will not be made all at once or
according to a single plan it will be
built through concrete achievements
which first created the factor solitaire
solidarity then this gathering is by no
doubt one of those concrete achievements
which creates a de facto solidarity
allow me to conclude this / emphasis on
o'banion Europe by living to all our
European friends here the following knot
of a very special French a great
political and humanist figure high-level
diplomat of the French Republic and
visionary founder of the Human Rights
League his name is Justin Godard have to
switch a moment in French and quotes
Albania a New Ager ISM individual
familial local national said to rule ago
ISM
he may know sacrifise do prefab parlor
before on Albury por la première fois
just aunty Kiev a no sell more desert by
the puppy
condo pouvez pas abandon a sons aunt
hello fellas I have to precise that this
striking not wasn't written on October
last year but hundred years ago in a
beautiful book titled well Bonnie and
meaning of song hunter Albania 1921 dear
and precious friends here today
big or small rich or poor near or far we
all are just people and you will never
ever regret being today's best friends
of Albania we may be small but we are
big of hearts we may be poor but we are
rich of character and we live according
to the principle set out in the first
paragraph of our old common law the
house of the Albanian belongs to God and
to the guests anytime all of you you are
welcome to be our guest of honor from
now until the end of times
thank you for coming thank you for
listening thank you for your support but
in there it's may God bless you and all
your countries
very much prime minister and now let me
invite on J Blenko which Prime Minister
of Croatia to the floor
thank you very much Oliver the Ursula
dear Charlotte dear ad
Mila Anna and Prime Minister's passive
ski dear ladies and gentlemen's friends
of Albania if I may call you that way
today I'm very pleased that so many of
you are attending this Albania donors
conference and I particularly would like
to thank to all so life on the line and
the whole team of the European
Commission for organizing it because one
of the fundamental principles of the
European Union is solidarity and this
solidarity is on full display today both
European and global Albania are closed
Adriatico and its people were hit by a
horrible earthquake that took away 51
lives injured over 3,000 people and
caused major infrastructural damages
around Duras swift reaction by the Union
to the crisis in Albania and the
organisation of this conference
demonstrates that the European Union is
effective in implementing its concepts
in particular the humanitarian
development Nexus the EU has already
developed an extensive cooperation with
Albania a country whose future belongs
in the European Union
therefore Croatia is organizing the
Zagreb summit which editors mentioned
with the support of char and Ursula in
order to reinvigorate the institutional
dynamics of our neighboring countries
from the Western Balkans towards the
European Union in the years to come when
we received the news about the urk
earthquake on the 26 November the
immediately dispatched 15 rescuers and
eight search dogs who will fly directly
to the earthquake hit area by the
Croatian air force two days later my
government adopted a decision to send a
humanitarian aid in worth of 1 million
Croatian kunas in tents sleeping bags
blankets sheets canned food first aid
kits and power generators the Croatian
Red Cross complemented further aid in
the weeks to come and through European
Commission's Emergency Response
Coordination Center for civil engineers
we immediately deployed a team of five
engineering experts and three civil
protection experts last week my
government donated a sum of 1 million
euros aimed at reconstruction and
infrastructure in the area of health and
education while providing our aid our
main concern should be to listen and
follow the requests made our friends in
Albania our assistance has to be focused
and partly driven only that way our
assistance will have long-term
sustainable effect we are here to be
working better together and help our
friends thank you
thank you very much Prime Minister now
let me invite my colleague Janice to
present us the video about the
earthquake and the emergency response
that has been provided there Thank You
president underline resident Michele
president prime ministers distinguished
participants ladies and gentlemen good
afternoon and welcome also from my side
I'm really grateful for everyone to be
here today before we watch the video let
me just say that no image and no words
can fully describe what Albania went
through last year in the early morning
hours of the 26th November and in the
days that followed that was a very
strong earthquake the strongest in
decades and it hit the western part of
the country affecting mostly densely
populated tirana and Duras claimed
thousands of lives injured hundreds of
people more than 11,000 houses turned to
rubble and tens of thousands of
properties were damaged
there was also extensive damage to
schools health facilities and public
infrastructure the impact of the
earthquake on public services was severe
and many people in the affected areas
saw their livelihoods vanish all this in
a matter of seconds seconds that lasted
for eternity
the intensity of the earthquake and the
scale of the damage made make it
impossible for the local authorities to
cope on their own so on the very day of
the earthquake albanian authorities
requested European assistance through
the Union Civil Protection mechanism the
response from the member states and
other states participating in this
mechanism was immediate and it was
generous within only a few hours of the
disaster
the European Union search and rescue
teams were operating on the ground in
Brussels the Emergency Response
Coordination Center played a central
role in facilitating the arrival of
in-kind assistance on the day after the
earthquake the EU civil protection team
was already in Duras and in Tirana
coordinating the assessment of unit area
needs and the collection and
distribution of in-kind assistance the
EU civil protection team also led
together with the Albanian authorities
the assessment of damage the damage
assessment coordination cell which was
set up for this purpose was crucial for
a quick well coordinated and reliable
process of damage assessment it
coordinated hundreds of international
structural engineers and provided input
to the post-disaster needs assessment
report that colleagues from the European
Union the United Nations and the World
Bank will present to you shortly
on the 5th of December just days after
taking the office I visited the affected
region in Albania I met with the
Albanian authorities to express European
Union Solidarity in those challenging
times
I spoke with diplomatic corpse and the
UN resident coordinator to make sure
relief and assessment efforts were well
coordinated I announced emergency aid
relief for immediate food shelter and
psychosocial support to vulnerable
people and I visited some of the worst
affected areas to assess the situation I
spoke to some of those who lost their
homes this I must say was not an easy
experience but at the same time I saw
firsthand the incredible commitment of
the Albanian and European Union's first
responders to save lives and alleviate
suffering and I want to use this
opportunity to thank each and every
member state that contributed for your
generosity and for the support offered
to our Albanian neighbors ladies and
gentlemen we stood by Albania providing
emergency assistance for as long and for
as much as it was needed but European
solidarity does not stop where emergency
ends the devastating earthquake showed
the importance for Albania and for us
all to be well prepared for a crisis the
EU stands ready to support Albania also
in improving its preparedness and
resilience the expertise capacities and
experience of our union civils
protection mechanism remains available
to the Albanian authorities for their
efforts to strengthen the Iranian
national civil protection system
ladies and gentlemen solidarity is the
guiding principle of European civil
protection solidarity guided European
Union's emergency relief and it will
also guide European Union's recovery
support to Albania
thank you on the 26th of November 2019
Albania was hit by a devastating 6.3
magnitude earthquake the earthquake was
the strongest to hit Albania in 30 years
and it caused extensive damage in 11
municipalities including the two most
urbanized Tirana and jurors
51 people lost their lives and at least
nine hundred thirteen people were
injured we shall be Mia telephone out
ice as soon as Porter hiders paid for it
I won't let it be my part 17,000 people
have lost their homes in a freak
manometer in Africa nothing from hero
arts black cinema a kind of freely I can
handle enough todos go ahead Jimmy
there's nothing from the Sierra standard
search the peace and quiet of course
caiman avoid burnished P you do them
over 300 educational institutions and 30
health facilities have been damaged
[Music]
at each new concept musical and or not
damn it communication can you get mad
but neither can give keep Italian
[Applause]
Albanians from across the country and
around the world mobilized immediately
to support their fellow citizens
the European Union its member states and
other countries immediately sent aid
search-and-rescue teams and engineers
solidarity is at the heart of our
European Union it binds together our
cultures important languages
we stand for one another and today we
stand for oh babe
[Music]
now we continue with the presentation of
the post-disaster needs assessment first
I would call
[Music]
you